hey youtubers is Charlie so we finally
got some footage of the Hulk from the
set of thor ragnarok if he didn't know
he was in the movie before you
definitely know now so I'm gonna play
these clips and then we'll talk about
the footage and I'm gonna talk a little
bit about grace cerebral Hulk hello it's
your humble servant Mark Ruffalo waiting
to shoot some Hulk scenes in my
legendary man cancelling suit it's
glamorous but someone has to do it your
humble servant happy to smash all of
Asgard we don't know if it's gonna be
taking place on multiple planets there
been a lot of rumors about that the Hulk
on Asgard how the hell does he get there
and what's gonna be his arc in this film
other than to just squash Loki for the
second time just cannot wait for that
reunion it's gonna be so much fun so the
biggest rumor is that we're gonna get
like a cerebral version of Hulk which is
basically like grey Hulk you have savage
Hulk which is like bigger stronger he
basically gets bigger faster as it gets
madder when there was the big color derp
with the Hulk initially what they ended
up doing is is they ended up writing in
some backstory to make grey Hulk make
sense so the logic is is that grey Hulk
has all the same powers of normal green
savage Hulk so he's able to retain more
of his Banner persona more of his
intelligence so under normal
circumstances you know what you've seen
in Avengers all the other films that
he's been in is that the minute he
changes he becomes the Hulk you can
barely get through to him like even
black widows magic vagina lullaby is
barely able to calm him down that can be
a lot of fun because you go from zero to
code GREEN Hulkbuster brofist moments
but you also don't get the chance to see
him as banner with the powers of the
Hulk and there been a lot of different
incarnations of the Hulk with various
states of intelligence like a Hulk that
can talk as banner and reason his banner
while he's hulked out which is basically
what you want somebody who could take on
Thanos and live to tell the tale but
also has banners genius-level scientist
mind
so you've probably heard an Avengers age
of Ultron how Joss Whedon cut one big
whole thing out and was like I told them
that they could use this in a future
movie and it was basically the gray Hulk
but behind the scenes in reality like
that wasn't exactly what he was going
for
what Joss Whedon wanted to do in that
film was show the Hulk's version of the
Hulk like what happens if the Hulk were
to Hulk out which they actually did
during the Avengers vs. x-men access
storyline the Hulk's version of the Hulk
is called claw-like the name is just
reversed you know ha ha
very funny but he looks a little bit
different so even though I don't think
they're gonna do that exact thing I
think what we'll see is is a more
cerebral version of Hulk which isn't
exactly what Joss Whedon was talking
about but it's basically grey Hulk so
like even if they get really cerebral
with Hulk in the movie which sounds like
they will like banner will come to terms
with the green guy like they'll come to
an arrangement it won't be so much
banner versus the green guy because
that's typically what it is in the past
like he's afraid of the green guy but
then we actually learn and Mark Ruffalo
has talked about this a little bit that
the green guy is just as afraid of
Banner his banner is of the green guy so
they get into a little bit of that but
you have to remember that there's a
whole bunch of stuff going on in this
movie so it's not gonna be a Hulk movie
but they're basically wedging like a
Planet Hulk type storyline in where he
basically just goes gladiator all over
everyone and if you're wondering why
Hulk and Thor were not in Captain
America Civil War it's because the
Brousseau said they wanted it to feel
like people could die and it's so hard
to kill Thor and the Hulk it's almost
impossible to kill the hole that it just
wouldn't have felt real it would have
been gods versus men and they really
wanted men versus men so like you could
take Iron Man out of his suit and kill
him you could kill Captain America you
could kill Bucky they just they wanted
it to feel a little more equal vision
and Scarlet Witch are kind of pushing it
but you can understand how she got tied
up in the MacGuffin so they had to
include her and they needed someone to
balance her out
so because her powers came from the mind
gem it only made sense that they would
include vision but that's the only
reason they snuck in otherwise they're
almost like God level powers so Hulk and
Thor had to ride the bench meaning that
with a Thor movie coming up that was
just the logical place to put hold
because as Loki likes to say in
comparison to the people on earth they
really are gods
so the Hulk vs gods is just a more
interesting story than the whole
so much a puny humans if you've ever
wondered what it looks like when he's
filming scenes this is pretty much it
like him in that mocap suit it's kind of
like a mocap suit he calls human
cancelling suit it's basically because
they delete the human once they
computerize it and then they add in the
Hulk on top of that so they basically
swap him out for the Hulk whenever
they're done but because of their mocap
technology they capture his performance
his facial movements and that's really
important for conveying the emotions
like what's going on in the Hulk's face
because the Hulk has to act to he can't
just be like this green CG monster just
flying all over the place but let me
know what you guys think about him
posting stuff from behind the scenes now
it seems like they're gonna be doing
this more and more like I talked about
this in another video
actors posting stuff from behind the
scenes they're doing it on spider-man
homecoming it's actually pretty cool and
for me it's like it's much more
interesting content showing us stuff
from the movie is way more interesting
than just telling us about it like you
could tell us that Hulk is gonna be
punching Asgardians but when you take a
look at one of these hands him just like
miming the Hulk punch so much more fun
so whatever they end up dropping from
behind the scenes it's gonna take them a
while to shoot the movie still be a lot
more of this kind of stuff so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and let me
know like if there's any specific Hulk
or Thor videos that you guys want me to
do when I do Ragnarok videos I know some
of you have been reading Marvel Civil
War Hulk is a big part of that I don't
wanna give away spoilers for that but
Amadeus Cho is the Hulk in the Marvel
Comics right now Bruce Banner doesn't
have powers part of the story of comic
book civil war is like this big Bruce
Banner arc that's supposed to come full
circle so because there's so much thor
ragnarok whole stuff happening I'll just
talk about Marvel Civil War stuff when I
talk about Thor stuff so get hype they
might talk a little about Thor Ragnarok
at Comic Con but because they just
started filming I'm not expecting any of
the actors to come the funny thing is is
that Tom Hiddleston is supposed to be
there for another movie so don't assume
that there won't be any Thor stuff but
they're mostly there to hype Doctor
Strange which is coming out of November
and guardians of the galaxy - I'll do a
guardians of the galaxy video pretty
soon like I'll do a big Marvel preview
that'll explain the stuff they're gonna
be dropping because there will be a lot
of footage but James Gunn has made it
sound like they're not gonna release any
of the guardians of the galaxy stuff
publicly so naturally like the internet
is fizz shaking but I'll talk about that
the next time I post the guardians of
the galaxy video where you guys wait for
my next video to post you can click here
for like the teaser
for Kid Flash on the flash season 3
Wally West is actually gonna get his
flash costume and you can click here for
my spider-man homecomings he's and you
can click here for my spider-man
homecoming teaser thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight